The Joe Rogan Experience we all know it
that formula at McDonald's why that's
the best tasting Coke and diet coke on
the planet why they have it because what
happens is when you when you're an
establishment like a restaurant you get
you know uh a formula like the the gun
has a blend and there's definitely a
different formula at the McDonald at
McDonald's oh there's been anything
written about this yeah yeah oh
interesting I didn't know that oh how go
if you're drive by McDonald's and you
get a Diet Coke you'll be like what the
[__] okay typically restaurants get
their soda syrups in plastic bags but
Coca-Cola does something different from
McDonald's the fast food chain gets
their Coke syrup delivered in stainless
steel tanks according to the New York
Times the material keeps the soda
fresher and your tongue can taste the
difference a thousand percent it can
right but is it a more potent Blend or
is it just because it's in the tanks I
don't know but it does taste so much
better it says their filtration system
is top tier
it disappeared wow there's all these
articles about it being subpoenaed and I
would say both like regular Coke you all
sudden you're like oh man and McDonald's
was an article yeah McDonald's does it
says there are many reasons the
Coca-Cola tastes so great at McDonald's
we simply follow the guidelines set by
Coca-Cola and take steps to ensure that
we serve a high quality Fountain
beverage well congratulations you do
that yes the water in Coca-Cola syrup
are pre-chilled before entering our
Fountain dispensers with the ratio syrup
set to allow for ice to melt oh so that
it doesn't get watered down with the ice
so they are making it stronger but
that's smart isn't this tell you
something though that how everything is
in the details you know what I mean like
this is something that probably a
restaurant would be like Coca-Cola would
say you should do this and they go
whatever right you know like whatever
we'll just we'll just put it in the gun
and and but I I believe that McDonald's
sticks to that because it is consistent
and it is so much different tasting even
what they said about their straws yeah
so their straws are typically wider than
the typical straw so you have a
different amount yeah give it to me
right my face hole you [__] [__] my
mouth with Coke yeah
yeah big old fat tube of it so [__]
extra syrupy because what if the ice
melts yeah with the ice melts even
though ice is better there they have
better eyes they have better they have
filtered water they said there you go
by the way we're not paid by McDonald's
for this no I don't even eat that stuff
but if I did
it's filet of fishes I could eat five of
those really I love fillets of fishes I
don't even know what that is McDonald's
has this thing too where there's a
temperature swing where it goes from
being the best thing you can eat at that
moment right like this unedible dog food
right yeah you like throw this down I
was uh in California a few months ago
and I had a quarter pounder it was
actually quite a while ago 10 months ago
and I had a quarter pounder for the
first time in [__] forever but I was
starving yeah and I had to eat and I was
headed to the airport and let me just
pulling this drive through real quick
and get a quarter pounder it's so sweet
yeah like I could taste the sugar in a
Quarter Pounder their bread even is I
think yeah it tastes like a pastry yeah
I was like this is interesting it was
very good yeah I enjoyed it I really do
I'm a quarter pounder fan yeah I don't
know what they're doing but it's it's
[__] delicious that's the thing I
think you really notice about certain
foods when you stay away from them is
that when you reintroduce them you go oh
I didn't realize that I was this is this
tastes way different yeah way different
I thought it was going to taste like an
In-N-Out cheeseburger yeah like a
cheeseburger like in and out is the gold
standard for me for for fast food places
that's the you can't [__] with it enough
but they have a stand and and Five Guys
they have stayed I mean in and out has
high standards oh yeah but whether or
not they are for your palette you can't
negate that they have high standards
some people hate their fries I know you
hate their fries you've seen them chop
the potatoes I just wish they did it in
beef Tallow because they doing some
[__] seed oils that's what that's
what they yeah I'm sure what is it what
does uh in and out use oil for their
fries everybody uses like canola oil
which is basically industrial lubricant
that stuff was invented to lube up
machines really sunflower oil same [__]
yeah you're not supposed to get that
much sunflower oil in your body at one
point in time it's not normal
but they definitely I've seen sounds
healthy doesn't it it does actually
sometimes sounds good that shit's not
healthy they watch them they're chopping
the produce right there oh yeah right
in front of you the the meat is fresh
it's not frozen and then you taste it
nice biblical verse on the bottom of the
cup oh that's so sweet it's beautiful
you know what I love flying Dutchmans
Yeah Yeah the secret menu yeah that's
what I get the secret menus is really
fascinating they have it I know it's
wild yeah animal style and all that jazz
yeah nothing's on no not printed though
yeah how do you find that out I don't
know somebody yeah somebody told me
about the first time and then I Googled
it and it's it's much more extensive
than you it's not like two or three
things oh yeah it's a [__] tone it's a
lot of things yeah things I've never
even heard of before yeah it's a lot
yeah yeah but it's [__] delicious I'm
a fan I'm a fan it did it's such a
different taste though than a McDonald's
burger McDonald's burger is like
it was sweet I'd like to know how much
what how many gr how many grams of sugar
is in a Quarter Pounder it's
I'm telling you it's got to be from that
bread too there's got to be from
everything it seems like it's from the
ketchup too it seemed like the
condiments had some higher sugar content
yeah it just tasted like it had sugar in
it like I'm real sensitive to that so I
eat I'm like it was good though I also
love a Chick-fil-A Sandwich oh I love a
Chick-fil-A yeah I love your wife's joke
about them
she's so funny man she's great oh she's
so funny 10 grams 10 grams of sugar
that might be the bread okay so it's too
natural and eight added so it must be
eight grams of sugar in the bread yeah
yeah that's in a Quarter Pounder yeah
that's kind of a lot
yeah like a really sugary drink maybe
it's a ketchup even yeah that's what I
was saying too I felt like the ketchup
was kind of sweet
so it's probably the bun and the ketchup
good though so good
it's a good move to put that eight grams
in there yeah it's so [__] good it
makes it more delicious if you're only
looking for something delicious you ever
heard of the McDonald's secret menu no I
have some weird [__] on here like this
the land sea and air Burger it's fillet
chicken and burger the difference is
though I feel like if you'll stab you if
you order that if yeah if you order that
first of all I think they'd be like the
[__] are you talking about look at this
mccrape the gangbang shut the [__] up
I swear are you serious I don't know
which place is gonna really know about
them but I've seen people ask like they
follow through with a video and go ask
for some of this stuff what there's a
weird viral good thing going on right
now with them because they have a
Grimace milkshake yeah people are making
some crazy videos about like what
happened to me after I drink oh like red
band did with uh 100 yeah whatever red
band did with Pepsi spice no did you
never knew about that no oh
it's the greatest troll red band ever
pulled off really red band bought Pepsi
spice.com and then he documented his
enjoying delicious Pepsi spice and so as
he's drinking Pepsi spice he's losing
weight he's getting blood in his
diarrhea he's dying at the end he's
making videos this is like young red
band Pepsi spice project promo
take away
I don't know what this has to do with
anything oh my God is he blowing himself
and doing stuff but yeah so he's filming
himself drinking Pepsi spices myself
so anyway he so he made he bought Pepsi
spice.com and he had to give it to Pepsi
after a while oh really but I mean I
think it still exists somewhere online
but they they came to him and they were
like hey [__] we'll kill you
because he's it went viral you know at
the time like whatever viral is in the
year 2001. imagine like the the threat
from a corporation like that oh my God
for it uh the Pepsi spice project
yeah it's very funny wait continues to
add I liked the stamp yesterday I'm
afraid to have sex I keep thinking that
my over caffeinated sperm would blow a
hole through the back of a girl's head
it's just so stupid it's so stupid but
that's the funnest thing to do is a
stupid bit